so i'm going to talk about uh some of
what i'm going to talk about is joint
work with the ninja day and muscle some
of it's just without command
um
okay so
uh in this this week we're supposed to
talk about functional inequalities and
discrete spaces but i want to start by
talking about functional inequalities on
gaussian space and i apologize to people
who were here for the last workshop
because i have to repeat a reasonable
amount of what elk and i said but i
think there's enough people who weren't
here
so
um
okay so i want to start out by
considering two gaussian random
variables
um each one is in rn and so the joint
distribution is an r2n
mean zero
and each one by itself is standard
gaussian
but they have some correlation between
them right
and uh there's a very beautiful theorem
okay so
what i want to do is i want to ask
given some
event can it be that there's a very good
probability of both x and y landing in
the event
okay and there's a very nice theorem
about this which is due to christa
burrell in the 80s
which says that this probability is
maximized if i take a to be a half space
and
i can even make it a little bit stronger
so i i give you two events
and i want to ask you to maximize the
probability that x is in one event and y
is in the other
and this is still maximized by half
spaces and not only that but the half
spaces should be parallel
so the theorem says
that for all
a and b this probability
is bounded by some other probability
probability that x1 is smaller than
phi inverse
of the measure of a
and y1
is smaller than phi inverse
of the measure of b
and here phi
is the gaussian cdf function
and so you'll see here that what i've
written here on the right
is the probability that x is in some
event which is a half space of measure
the same measure is a and this is the
event that y is in some half space with
the same measure as b
and so what this inequality is really
saying is that is that this probability
is maximized for parallel half
spaces okay
all right so this is an inequality about
sets but we should be talking about
functional inequalities
uh yeah row is positive thanks um
you can you can talk about row being
negative two and then everything that i
say will also work for negative row
except that the inequalities will
reverse
so
all right
um
so here's a functional version
which is equivalent to the original
version and so what i do is i define j
as a function from the square
to well i guess it maps into zero one
and uh there's a parameter rho which
i'll sometimes suppress
but j of a b
and rho
is the probability
that x one
is smaller than phi inverse
of a
and y1 is smaller than phi inverse
of b
right and sort of rho is implicit in the
joint distribution here right so the way
i've defined j is it's
the noise sensitivity of two parallel
half spaces with these volumes
and then the point of making this
definition is now i can sort of write
this theorem in a way that looks uh
maybe a little bit nicer
so uh
for all f and g
mapping from rn
to 0 1
the expectation of
j
f of x g y
is smaller than j of the expectations
okay
so of course it's pretty easy to see how
this one implies the original right what
i do is i set f and g to be indicator
functions
and then if i set f and g to be
indicator functions then the point is
that
you can easily see that j of 0 0
is the same as j of 1 0 and j of 0 1.
those are all 0 and on the other hand j
of 1 1
is 1.
so when i plug in indicator functions
here
this thing on the left-hand side is just
the indicator that they both land in the
set right and so this left-hand side
here is the same as the left-hand side
here and j was just defined so that the
right-hand sides are the same
okay so the functional inequality
implies the set one and you can actually
go the other way around too um
but i think maybe um
i won't say that today so they're
actually equivalent
okay so
the sort of
the broad thing that i want to talk
about is quite vague i guess but
let me write it like this so
i want to ask
for which
joint distributions
and for which functions
do i have an inequality like this
okay so some things are very easy right
so if i take uh distributions
where x and y are independent
then this is always going to hold
right so so really the question is
for which distributions with non-trivial
dependence between x and y doesn't
inequality like this hold right so i'm
trying to ask for distributions where
there's dependents
but you can't find events
that are
very correlated
okay so here's a here's a definition
that measures the dependence of two
variables
um
x and y
have any correlation
rho
if
for all f for all functions f and g
the covariance
of f of x
and g of y
is smaller than rho times the square
root of the product of the variances
j is not concave
if j will concave then this would follow
from jensen's inequality
if j was concave jointly in both
in each variable individually j is
concave
yes
okay so i'll tell you what's very
important about j that's going to come
up later
so
i write j
x x for the double derivative of j in
the first variable
right and then i can look at the hessian
all right so concave
would be that right
but it actually satisfies this
okay so michelade proposed the name row
concave for such functions
and uh and in fact uh when i have
gaussian variables this inequality is
true for every row concave function
that's sort of the crucial property
okay so uh so here is some measure of
dependence right let's say the things
have uh correlation row if
they satisfy something that's stronger
than koshi schwartz because i can put a
row on the right hand side
okay and you could ask does do things
that
have l2 any functions
so i mean you'll notice that uh
yeah okay
any functions
j
i fix the function j and i ask this
question for this function j
right
okay so the first question is does
running correlation row imply
star and the answer is clearly not
because
so what if i take x and y to be
bernoulli
with correlation rho
right so that means
so it's pretty easy to check that uh
bernoulli variables with correlation row
also have ready correlation rho
and the reason is that there are sort of
no non-trivial functions to test for
because
uh this
equation is affine invariant and so
there's nothing to check
right
okay and then for bernoulli's with
correlation row i can take my oven a to
be the event that x is one and my event
b to be the event that y is one
and then i have probability
that x equals one
y equals one
is 1 plus rho
over 4.
okay and now
well if i plug in on the other hand
j
of these probabilities where each of
these events has probability of half
this thing turns out to be
1 4
plus
i think
if i try and do it by memory i'll get it
wrong
1 4 plus 1 over 2 pi
r sine
of rho
so this is what you get for j the half a
half and you can test it because what's
j of a half a half it's the uh you can
write it as the integral over r two
the gaussian measure against a wedge
and then the question is just what's the
angle of the wedge so
that explains that and now the point is
that
arc sine
is a concave function on the interval
zero to one
and so this is always smaller than that
okay so the answer is
uh any correlation rho does not imply
this
okay on the other hand
you can see that
if i have two variables with any
correlation rho then this is clearly the
maximum correlation you can get between
events
right and that's just because
uh if you plug in the two events into
this then that's what you get
okay and so i guess one thing that you
can see from this is that
uh in some sense gaussians gaussians
with correlation rho have are less noise
stable than bernoulli's with correlation
row
all right
so
half spaces are the most noise stable
sets for gaussians
um
and their noise stability is strictly
smaller than
the best noise stable sets for
bernoulli's
this is
let's consider just sets of measure half
right
this is the best noise stability i can
get for two gaussian sets
of measure half
and uh
yeah
sorry
uh i i define this thing to be the noise
stability of a set
the probability that two correlated
things fall in it
okay so
and i guess uh
what i'm hoping is this the main message
of the talk is that
um
row correlation does not imply that your
noise stability is less than gaussian
but row correlation plus lots of small
effects does
and this is a very vague statement
because unfortunately what we know so
far is pretty vague too
uh anyway let me give an example
in this example is the famous majority
of stabilist theorem
which is due to muscle adrenaline on the
scavenge
and it goes like this so
now i'm going to move from gaussian
space to discrete space
so i consider the cube
plus minus 1 to the n
and i take x
to be a uniformly random
element of this space
and y
well so i define y i by for each bit
i set y i to equal x i with probability
x i
with probability rho
and
with probability 1 minus y i take an
independent random sample right and so
now what this means is that for every
bit
um every bit has correlation rho between
x and y
right and they're independent
okay and so now the theorem says this
that i look at this function i look at
this equation star
and i want this to hold for the cube
and of course it's not true
because of this example right this
example i can just look at functions of
the first bit it won't be true but
it's true if i add an error term to the
right hand side
and the error term depends on the
influences right so i don't really want
to define influences if you don't know
what they are but basically if f and g
don't depend on
any one bit too much
then this inequality is true
okay so this is one example
of something that answers my question
right so the example is if i have row
correlated
uh vectors on the discrete cube and
functions which don't depend much on any
one coordinate
then it satisfies the gaussian noise
stability bound
okay now i want to give you a proof of
this
um and this proof is
uh it's not the original proof but it's
it's a proof that was joint work with
within indian alcanon
and the way the proof is going to work
is i'm going to prove a two-point
inequality and then tensorize
okay so uh i want to prove a two-point
inequality
so let n equals one
okay i want to consider this i'm going
to tailor expand it
around the expectation of f and the
expectation of g
so
there's a first order term
right so it's uh
it is the difference in the first
variable times
the first derivative of the
point that i'm taylor expanding around
and then
yeah that's true okay thank you
okay and then this is the first order
difference
okay and now i get a second order term
and the second order term is a quadratic
form
i'm going to start writing
f-tailed and
g-tilled for f minus the expectation
and then what i have here is the hessian
of j
f tilden g tilled
okay
and now there's a third order term and
now i'm going to give up and just say
order
of f tilled cubed
okay so now i'm going to take
expectation of both sides and what
happens when i take expectation of both
sides is that the first order terms
vanish
and let's see what happens to the second
order term
so uh
expectation of j f g is
equal to j of the expectations
plus the second order term and the
second order term when i multiply this
out is a half
and then what i have in the matrix
is uh
the variance
of f
times j x x
on the bottom i have the variance of g
times j y y
and here i have the covariance
on the diagonals
and then there's a third order error
term
okay
so i haven't done anything complicated
now
okay so now if you look at this matrix
um
okay well i told you up there that this
matrix with the rows is negative
definite right so there's
so so basically what i want to do is i'm
going to apply the randy correlation
definition there to replace this
covariance by rho times the product of
the square roots of the variance
and then this condition here on the
hessian being negative will tell me that
the second order term is actually
non-positive
all right so you put that all together
and i claim that i've showed
this is smaller than
j of the expectations
plus
something which is uh
of order
of a third order
so that's the base case of the induction
there's almost nothing there it's just a
taylor expansion and then
a
bound on the second order term
okay
so now i want to do the inductive step
and actually i claim that the inductive
step
is almost trivial so let me just cheat a
little bit and i'm going to prove the
inductive step without the error term
okay so i suppose
and this is unfortunately not true
that the expectation of j of f of x
g of y
is smaller than j of the expectations
for
x
having n minus one variables and y
having n minus one variables okay and
now i'm going to do it for n variables
right so expectation of j
so now f is a function of x and x n
and g is a function of y
and yn
and this expectation is the same as
if i take the expectation
of the conditional expectation
right and now the point is that
conditioned on
conditioned on xn
this thing is actually only a function
of n minus one variables right
so
i apply this the inductive step
conditionally and i get
j of and in here it's expectation of f
given xn
expectation of
g given yn
well uh yeah okay so i can put an x and
y in here but in fact uh
in fact it doesn't matter because all of
the other x's are independent from y n
right so
okay and now what i have in here is
something of the same form but now
what's inside are both functions of one
variable
and so i apply the base case of the
induction
and i get this is smaller than
j of the expectations
okay so this was the cheating version
where i didn't use the error term but
now
if you want to do the induction with the
error term you just do exactly the same
thing but now you have to keep track of
what happens to the error term when you
do the induction right
and i think i might leave that bit out
unless someone really wants to see it
i'll just tell you what happens at the
end
what you actually get
is expectation of j
of f and g
is smaller than what you wanted
plus a narrow term
which looks like the sum
of
of some martingale differences cubed
so
where in here
f i
is the expectation of f
given x 1
x i
so that's what you get if you follow
through the induction and keep track of
what happens to the error terms and
you'll notice that there's a cube here
on these martingale differences and
that's actually quite important
okay uh
okay so actually let me uh
i'm going to call this a theorem
this is something
that's true for any functions f and g on
the cube
that you have this sort of gaussian
noise sensitivity bound with an error
term
okay and now two remarks
so it turns out that from this sort of
general statement you can deduce both
the majority of stabilized theorem
and you can actually deduce the
burrell's theorem for for gaussians well
actually so the noise the majority of
stables there implies burrell's theorem
so that's a little bit redundant what i
just said but to get from here to the
braille thing is actually very easy
and you don't actually have to go
through majority stabilize so let me
show that first
okay so
i can i consider a function
from rn to 0 1
and i define
a function
f tild
from
plus minus 1
to the m
to 0
1. by f
of x
f tilde of x is f of
well i'm going to plug in you know 1
over square root of k sum of x
i
etc 1 over square root k sum of x i
and let's see so the first sum i'm going
to take from i equals 1 up to k and the
last one
is going to go from i equals
something up to m
right so what i'm doing right is i'm
dividing my bernoulli variables into
chunks and i'm taking this sort of
binomial for each chunk and normalizing
it so it sums to a gaussian
okay
and what you'll notice about this
function f tilde is that it's one over
square root calypsias
right meaning if i flip a bit of f tilde
ah sorry that's not true i have to
assume that my function my original
function is lipschitz
right if i flip an original if i flip a
bit
of my function f tilde then it will
change one of these binomials by m over
square root of k and so it'll change f
tilde by most l over square root of k
and the point is then that if i look at
this error term
right this error term can be bounded by
the effect of flipping the i plus one
bit
right so this is even true without
expectation
this thing is smaller than l over square
root k
right and so when i cube it and take
expectation this thing is smaller than l
cubed
over k to the three halves
okay
and so now if i sum this thing up
from i
equals one up to okay so i made a
problem here which is that i have an n
here and i have an n here so let me make
this a d
okay so i sum this up
from i equals one up to n
and i get here
this times n
okay and now the point is that k
is like n over d
right
so this whole right hand side
is order n to the minus a half
sorry
yeah and
mixed up my ends and m's and d's but
hopefully it's clear that uh
that when i when i apply this limit then
the error term vanishes okay and the
point is that you really need the third
order error term here right if you had a
second order error term then nothing
would vanish right and so you really
need this
this uh
the statement is is true for js that
satisfy a second order condition
okay
and uh okay so i also claimed that you
can get from here to the majority
stabilist theorem
i think let me not go into that too much
so
what you have to do is you have to show
that that these things can be bounded in
terms of the maximum influence and you
use some hypercontractivity and so on
okay
okay so now all of this was actually
discussed at the last workshop but the
sort of departing point for today
is
that i want to point out
uh that actually this proof works in
greater generality than uh than what i
said before in particular it doesn't
require
uh iid variables x1 through xn and y1
through yn
so let me state two conditions and i'm
going to claim that the proof works for
an arbitrary joint distribution
satisfying these conditions
okay
so the proof of the theorem works
provided
so what i did is i applied this
induction thing
and i assumed that at every step of the
induction i have sort of row correlation
so this is the condition that i needed
for the inductive step to work and i
also applied the base case of the
induction every time
and
so
so basically i'm saying that these two
uh
rainy correlation hypotheses are
essentially all that i needed for the
proof to go through
right at every step when i do the
induction i need to be able to put a row
on the off diagonals of my matrix
which is no longer there but
okay and this is for all i so
so i guess the statement is if there
exists a filtration
f tild uh
if there exists a filtration f1 through
fn except that this is true then then
this statement of the theorem also holds
okay so uh
that's all very nice but you know it
doesn't seem very useful maybe so
what i want to do today is give you a
couple examples uh where we can check
this condition
and um
unfortunately
uh we don't really know very much about
this yet so i would like to say that
there are a lot of interesting examples
but i can only give you a couple right
now and hopefully there'll be more
okay so my examples are going to come in
two main categories
the first category is when x1 through xn
and y1 to yn are come from a markup
chain
uh okay so the proof works as long as
there exists
a sequence
uh
of sigma algebras which are increasing
and have this property this is what i
need i don't even technically need my
functions f and g to be functions of
disjoint sets of variables but i guess
in the examples there will be so i
really just need a sequence of
synchrologists
okay
so my first example
to suggest that this is maybe an
interesting result
is
i consider markov chain
for now let's suppose it is finite
states
call the state space s
and call the transition matrix
p
okay
now actually i don't just want one
markov chain i want two markup chains
so actually
now i'm going to think of a markov chain
on ordered pairs of the state space
and some transitions
p tilled
okay and now let me suppose some things
about p tilde
so first of all
i'm going to impose a condition that
says that the sort of marginal markov
chain i get by just looking at the first
coordinate is going to be according to
this and same for the second coordinate
so what does that mean
right so for all
uh
i k
the sum for j and l
of okay so p tilde right it's a markov
chain on s cross s so to write its
transitions i need two pairs of
vertices right so
uh i
j
k l
this thing should be equal to p
i k
right
and then similarly
if i just fix jl and i sum over ik
this is just saying that the marginals
of the markup chains are the right ones
and now i need a condition that's going
to tell me that the markov chains are
sort of at each step or
have correlation at most row
and uh
well if you just think about it for a
second then this is what you come up
with
for all
v and w
the sum
of
e
i j
k l
uh v k wl right so this is what i'm
saying is i'm starting at position i j
and i'm looking at uh
so i guess this is a function
of
um
the next state in one
right so v
is in uh
did i make a mistake
this one
let's see so so this is this sum over jl
is marginalizing out whatever happens to
the second
to the second guy
right is it not um
just to work out
is that saying i tell oh yeah right
so i'm telling you where
where is the
okay maybe
i have to sorry it's the not the right
time for me to think about this but but
the condition that i want is for the
marginals of the markup chain to be
these marginals okay right and the other
condition that i want is no matter where
i am
the next step that i take is not going
to be too correlated between the two
chains
right and let's hope i didn't make a
mistake on this one
so this thing should be smaller than rho
times the square root
so i have a sum over k now
of uh
and the sum of the k now
and this should be true for all uh
v and w
which sort of have mean zero
yeah this is for all ij
all right so what i'm really saying is i
tell you where your two coordinates are
right now and then they're both going to
take a step and those steps are not
going to be too dependent on one another
so something is killed
so
after you corrected it right
the way you corrected it is like
assuming that they evolved independently
you don't want them to evolve
independently so i think the way you
wrote it before
how about we stick with the way that i
said it and not the way that i wrote it
right they have the right marginals
or the wk squared
squared thank you squared
i want to think of w k and v k as being
functions of the position and then and
then this thing should be the variance
right and that thing should be the
covariance
okay
happen to be up
okay
so anyway i claim that when i write
these conditions down correctly then uh
what it implies
is uh
are exactly these two
things okay
so what i'm saying is that for such a
markov chain
i have an inequality for the noise
stability right it goes like this
expectation of j
f so this is a function potentially of
the whole path
and a function g that's also potential
potentially the whole path this is
smaller than j the expectations
plus
plus a third of average okay let's make
this a little bit more interesting with
an example
derive this without even knowing your
proof just deriving this from your
statement by
injecting the markov chain into the
definition of f and g does that make any
sense uh so you mean you want to go from
the original majority stabilist theorem
right to the statement from europe
right
uh
you can oh from from my proof
that's what he's done yeah that's what
i'm doing essentially well but you
observing that the proof can can also
apply here i'm saying i don't even care
about the proof just from the statement
you're saying that because the updates
are generated independently
the function could take care of this
okay so i think maybe actually you can
do this straight from this statement
but uh but but i don't think you can get
this from the original majority of
stateless theorem because then you have
an error term which is not written like
this which is written
yeah maybe
so i think my second example you can't
do this but we'll see maybe you can also
okay so uh
so i guess this is still part of example
one
let me call it example 1a
see i'm starting to run out of time so
uh
okay so let me take my state space
to be the cube
and my markup chain is going to be
at every time interval
i'm going to choose an index
and i'm going to choose a sign
and then i'm going to choose another
index and another sign in the following
way
with probability row
i'm going to set
j equals i
and tau equals sigma otherwise
i'm going to set
j
i'm going to choose j and tau
independently of i value sigma and i'm
going to set x sub i equals sigma sorry
x
right so this is the markov chain at
time t
and i'm setting its i coordinate to
sigma
and the markov chain at time t
the jth coordinate will be tau for the
other one
okay
so i claim that these transitions
satisfy
the conditions they're not they have
correlation rho
um
and uh okay and the other thing i claim
is that actually the stationary
distribution of this markov chain
is the row correlated distribution of
the cube
right
so
if you think for a minute right if i
start with something that's real
correlated and then i do this
then uh each coordinate afterwards
uh
well you know the coordinate i is going
to be row correlated
and uh all the other coordinates
well if they weren't chosen then they're
still independent
right well if they weren't chosen in
their stealth and stationary
distribution which was recorded
so let me say this again
stationary distribution
is real correlated distribution
sorry could you clarify this again so
uh
all the other coordinates remain the
same all the other coordinates remain
the same i'm just changing
one coordinate of each okay
and now okay
so
actually there's a special case of this
that i claim is still interesting rather
than looking function at functions of
the whole chain up till now i'm just
going to look at functions of the
endpoint
and what do i get when i look at
functions at the endpoint
well when i apply
okay so now i have a sum
from i equals 1
up to n of an error term
okay and now my point is that
actually the sum doesn't go from i
equals one up to n
and the reason is uh that this markov
chain mixes after a while
and so anything that happens
before time
n minus a constant times the mixing time
doesn't affect the other term or it
affects an exponentially small amount
okay
and
okay so now
i'm going to do something
so suppose that uh
the dimension on the cube and
the number of steps
no i don't
s is plus one
yeah
so i have a cube of a fixed size n and
now i'm running a markup chain on it for
a very long time
but the first bit doesn't affect it
right only only the last part
thank you
so i have m here and m there
right it's the ending time of the mark
of chain run for instance okay
now if my function is ellipsis
then this thing
well the error term
is at most l
times the mixing time
okay
so in particular
if l in this example is n to the minus a
half
like i was doing before for getting
barrell's theorem well you can see that
the mixing time of this is n log n and
so the return goes to zero
okay so
yeah thanks
so we haven't gotten very far it's
almost the end and i've got another
burrell theorem again
otherwise it won't move
i said sorry the error term is a cubed
and so i have an l cubed right thanks
okay so this was maybe not such an
interesting example because it got us
something that we knew before but it
sort of serves as a starting point for
considering other examples
um
so let me just sort of quickly say one
more example just in words
rather than considering the cube i can
consider linear orderings on an alphabet
of size n and i and there's you know
tons of markov chains that have been
studied for this one right so let me do
one which is
at time t i pick a card so okay it's a
deck of cards right my elements one up
to n
i pick a card in deck one
and with probability row i take the same
card from deck two
right otherwise i pick another random
cut from deck two and then i put them
both on top
okay this gives me some markov chain
right um it will uh so if i pick the
cards uniformly it will tend to be
uh each markup chain individually
converts to uniform right but they're
not uh independent right because they
tend to have the same cards on the top
right and so i claim that if you have a
lipschitz function
uh of the final of if you have a
lipsticks function of the stationary
distribution
in this markov chain with a small
lipsticks constant then you also get
gaussian noise stability for this model
right and and the lipsticks constant
that you have to take is going to be 1
over square root of n
um which is
sort of
large well it's
much smaller than
the the diameter i guess of the
of the uh of the state space right
yeah
uh
one of the root n what is smaller than
one
well okay so the the ellipses constants
that you have to take so it's quite
small right it's it's going to be one
over square root the number of letters
say right now the diameter
of the state space if i consider the the
distance where two things are connected
if i can go from one to the other is
order n
right and uh and so
this is a root n is less than n
uh
one over root n is less than one over
n i guess so what i'm saying is that my
function can take
uh
one over root n
one over one
one over one over smaller than n thank
you right so i guess what i'm saying is
that my function
my function is is is very much
independent of small changes in the
state space but it nevertheless sees the
whole space right it can vary widely
over the whole space but not by adjacent
transpositions so this these sort of
functions which can't see local things
but but are nevertheless non-trivial
globally they satisfy this new stability
okay
very quickly in words again the other
example that we have
instead of a markov chain so it's going
to be again a distribution on plus minus
1 to the n but now instead of
independent i take plus and minus 1 to
the n to be distributed according to an
easy model on some bounded degree graph
with a relatively high temperature
and then you can show that if the
temperature is not too high ah and then
i have to tell you what's y right what's
the noisy version is i run global
dynamics for a short time
okay and then you have to check that if
the temperature is
relatively high
then
then you don't have much correlation
between
a vertex at time 0 and a vertex at time
t
okay and then what you get so when you
check that
is you see that this
correlation condition holds
and then the next ingredient to get
something non-trivial is to show that
you can deal with the error term and it
turns out that some sort of spatial
mixing is enough to deal with the error
return
so let me not say anything more about
that
and go on to uh
some questions
okay
so
i guess what i've what i've tried to get
across is that if you have
distributions
which are not too correlated and depend
a lot on many small things then you get
a noise stability theorem for them that
says that they're not more noise stable
than gaussians
okay
um but this was only for global
functions right it's only for functions
that do not see small changes
right so you could ask and and do not
see small changes it was sort of in a
very strong sense because i asked for a
very small lipsticks constant now in the
majority of stabilist theorem
you don't have to ask for a small
lipsticks constant you can ask for low
influence and so the first question
is
what can you say
for functions which are not necessarily
global in the sense that they're very
smooth but which don't depend too much
on any one coordinate and this is sort
of i'm not even quite clear what the
question should be because the notion of
say influence of a coordinate in in
general is you know i mean you can make
definitions but but i'm not sure what's
what's quite right
and uh
and the second question
is maybe a little bit more specific but
not much
which is we can we can construct
examples of markup chains that satisfy
these sort of noise stability bounds
right but uh it's sort of one example at
a time right i mean i don't uh
right
so i guess the question here
is what sort of uh
what sort of joint distributions
arise like this right so
i have a i have a markov chain and i
evolve it
sort of twice in parallel independently
right what sort of stationary
distributions can i get from that
because every stationary distribution
that i can get from that sort of a
markov chain satisfies this
inequality so that's all thanks
more questions comments
so
at least in situations like easy
it's clear what is the influence and i
think this you know
so you choose a variable and then you
just
do one lover move on that variable right
so refresh it according to conditional
distribution and then so then you have
what is the expected you know right
you can ask what is the change
right so so you're right actually in the
case of a needing wall eating model the
question is well defined but i don't
know how to answer it
and uh and the reason is
um if you well
if you look at what you have to check
for this correlation condition to hold
then you end up having to condition on
uh
basically a bunch of vertices at times
zero and a bunch of vertices at time t
and this is a very non-markovian thing
to condition on and it makes things a
pain and one thing that that um
that it makes to be tricky is um when
you do the majority of stabilist theorem
and you want to so we gave this
condition in terms of uh
in terms of you know martingale errors
and if you want to apply hyper
contractivity to them get influenced
from that then you sort of need to use
the fact that you can commute
a noise operator with the martingale
and that really uses independence and so
i don't know how to do that
for the easy model
the question i already asked you so
maybe i asked everybody you have this
definition of strong concavity which
means that you take the hessian of your
function and you put a row
on the cross diagonal terms
and when rho is one this is just the
usual
definition of non-negativity of
direction and it's equivalent to the
concavity of the function which may
characterize
through two points
so when you have a row is there any
characterization with
two is not enough four is not enough as
you showed on the cube so
maybe 8 or 16.
i mean i should mention so one thing
that uh that michelle pointed out
before is that is that there's at least
one more interesting example of a row
concave function and this is uh well i
guess the hyper-contractive function if
you think about it um you can you can uh
prove the hyper-contractive inequality
just by plugging in a certain function
into this general statement and it turns
out to be real concave
so one other question in addition to
that is other interesting examples of
concave functions
okay
oh sorry
well often when you have some total
progression you can go to person so i
was wondering can you start or initially
it was the first result
is there an equivalent for questions
no the thing for poisson is not true
because it depends too much on one event
i think
that they are correlated right
what it
according to the means chain which has
in variance for each person
and always exponentially in time or
something like that
can you have such property for the
section
so i'm not sure if this is exactly the
same as but we didn't consider some sort
of poisson and what you get is uh it
doesn't matter if your error term is
second order or third order or fourth
order
it still contributes and the reason it
contributes is is because in poisson
it is controlled by rare events and so
the moments don't
decay so i think it's not true for
puzzle
sort of thing
it might be a different person than the
one you think